مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوين
لليوم الخامس على التوالي اسرائيل تقصف
غزه والفصائل وترد باستهداف مستوطنات
الغلاف
يوم عن حسم الرئاسه في تركيا اردوغان يقول
انه سيقبل بنتائج الانتخابات ايا كان
الاختراع يجب ان تكون على مراه من الجميع
الكويت تقفل باب الترشيح الانتخابات
البرلمان غدا والغانم يتقدم ويؤكد على
الشفافيه
في الرابع ايضا
مسح صحي وطني في السعوديه يستمر حتى 27 من
مايو
[موسيقى]
رحيل الفنان الكويتيه عبد الكريم عبد
القادر عن 81 عاما ونعي كبير في الكويت
والخليج
[موسيقى]
نبدا من التوتر المتصاعد على حدود غزه حيث
افادت مراسله العربيه باصابه مستوطنين
اثنين على الاقل جرى سقوط صاروخ في
مستوطنه قرب غزه الفصائل عاودت رفق
مستوطنات يسدود وعسقلان والنقب الغربي
وبالتوازي مع اعلان الجيش الاسرائيلي
استئناف استهداف منازل قيادي حركه الجهاد
في القطاع
مراسل العربيه فهذا من جهته باطراق عده
صواريخ مضاده للطائرات تجاه المقاتلات
الاسرائيليه في الوقت الذي دوت فيه سفاره
الانذار في المستوطنات المحاذيه لقطاع غزه
وكان الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن انه بدا هجوما
جديدا على مواقع في غزه بما اعلن مستشار
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي الساحلي انه لن
يكون هناك وقف للنار قبل وقف اطلاق
الصواريخ
هذا ولقي فلسطينيين مصرعهما برصاص الجيش
الاسرائيلي واصيب اثنان اخران اثر اقتحام
قوات خاصه مخيم بلاطه في نابلس يرتفع بذلك
عدد القتلى منذ بدء التصعيد الاسرائيلي
على غزه الى 33 قتيلا
[موسيقى]
من قطاع غزه ينضمرين الصحفي احمد حرب احمد
مرحبا بك ما هي اخر التطورات
نعم خالد اخر التطورات في قطاع غزه
الغارات الاسرائيليه والاستهدافات
الاسرائيليه ما زالت مستمره في كافه مناطق
القطاع اخر هذه الغارات كان استهداف لارض
زراعيه فارغه في بلده بيت حانون شمالي
القطاع وايضا تم استهداف منزل يعود لعائله
الزعنين ايضا في بلده بيت حانون الشماليه
القطاع هذا عدا عن القصف المدفعي في ايضا
شرق بلده بيت حانون شمال القطاع المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه قصفت عددا من المناطق
والمنازل في تلك المنطقه هذا بالاضافه ان
هناك استهدافات جرت في خان يونس في منطقه
عبسان الكبرى الشارقه مدينه خان يونس
وايضا استهداف في رفح في المنطقه الشرقيه
يعني نتحدث عن استهدافات متعدده ومختلفه
في كافه مناطق القطاع هذا عدا عن استهداف
العديد من المنازل في اليومين الماضيين
حسب ما اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي انه بدا
سياسه تنفيذ بدا بسياسه تدمير المنازل
لقاده حركه الجهاد الاسلامي منذ الامس
واليوم قصف الاحتلال ودمر اكثر من عشرين
منزل يعود لقاده حركه الجهاد الاسلامي كما
يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي هذا من جانب من
جانب اخر
الجانب الفلسطيني بمعنى ان حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي والفصائل الفلسطينيه معها تقوم
بايضا اطلاق الصواريخ باتجاه المستوطنات
والبلدات المحاذيه للقطاع سفارات الانذار
دوت في كافه المستوطنات الاسرائيليه
المحاذره للقطاع قبل خروجنا عن الهواء قبل
دقائق كان هناك اطلاق رشقه من الصواريخ
باتجاه البلدات الاسرائيلي شكرا جزيلا لك
يا احمد حرب من قطاع غزه
الى تركيا وقبل ساعتين تقريبا من الصمت
الانتخابي المقرر مساء اليوم تحسبا
الانتخابات يوم غدا الاحد يواصل مرشح
الانتخابات التركيه حشدت دعم الشعبيه
اردوغان الذي يدافع عن ارتفاعادين من
الزمن امام خصمه الابرز كيتشدار اوغلو
سينظم تجمعا شعبيا في منطقه شيرين فيلر
بالقرب من جامعه اولو في اسطنبول بينما
يزورك قبل مصطفى كما لا تترك من اسطنبول
ينضم الينا موفد العربيه طاهر بركه طاهر
مرحبا بك طاهر كيف هي الاجواء الان
الاجواء حماسيه جدا وصل الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان قبل قليل وبدا بخطابه امام هذا
التجمع الانتخابي الاخير قبل الصمت
الانتخابي الساعه السادسه مساء دعنا نشاهد
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان وهو يتحدث اتى وهو
بدا بحديثه عن قاسم باشا هذه المنطقه التي
ولد فيها ونحن هنا في منطقه تقسيم التي
تعرف تركيا هذه هذا الخطاب هو الاخير اذا
له قبل ان يصلي صلاه المغرب في ايه صوفيا
كان قبله تحدث سليمان سويلم وزير الداخليه
من على نفس المنصه اضافه الى رئيس حزب
العداله والتنميه في اسطنبول عثمان نوريكا
كباب هناك تركيز كبير على الجانب الامريكي
في الموضوع لانه سليمان سويلم قال قبل
قليل علانيه ان بايدن سينزعج غدا عندما
يرى نتائج الفوز فوز اردوغان وعوده الى
ولايه جديده في السلطه هؤلاء الحشود يحيون
رجب طيب اردو الان وهو لا يزال على المنصه
طبعا هذه الانتخابات هي انتخابات ليست
بالعاديه بالنسبه اليه هو تعود على الفوز
في العشرين عاما الاخيره ولكن هذه المره
المعركه قاسيه جدا امام معارضه موحده على
طاوله سداسيه امام معارضه مختلفه التوجهات
والاحزاب هذه المره الاولى التي يواجه
فيها هذا الامر خاصه بعد خسارته لرئاسه
بلديه خساره الحزب لرئاسه بلديه اسطنبول
وانقره في عام 2019 الرئيس اردوغان لا
يزال على المنصه يحيي الجمهور يحيي جمهور
حزب العداله والتنميه الذين تجمعوا
لرؤيته ومتحمسون جدا يغنون الاغاني
التابعه للحزب وهو يغادر الان هذه المنصه
طبعا نعرف يمشي بتثاقل نعرف انه عمره 69
عاما وتعرض لوعكه صحيه اثناء الحمله
الانتخابيه اضطر على اثارها
الانتخابي لثلاثه ايام ولكن اعاده كل
المعلومات وقالت ان صحته جيده وهو يتابع
على كل المرشح الاكبر عمره اكبر ب 74 عاما
اي كمالك هناك
كثير من المواطنين المصرين على ان ينتقلوا
الى المنصه لكي يحيوا الرئيس ويسلم عليه
والامن يحاول ان يتعامل مع الموضوع هناك
الاف من الاتراك يتجمعون هنا في وسط تقسيم
في وسط باي اوبلوس لمشاهده الرئيس هذه هي
الاجواء الان من هذه المنطقه حيث
يبدو انه لا يزال الرئيس اردوغان موجودا
واعتلى المنصه لعله سيتابع في خطاباته
الانتخابيه يحاولون استغلال
هذه هذا البرنامج الانتخابي يعني الى اخر
لحظه حتى السادسه مساء بعد نحو ساعتين
عندما ندخل حيز الصمت الانتخابي على فكره
بالمناسبه خالد كانت هناك المعطيات بشان
اعتقال نحو 15 شخصا من هؤلاء الذين توعدت
وزاره الداخليه ومديره الامن بالقاء القبض
عليهم ممن نشهروا معلومات مزيفه عن محرم
انجي المرشح الرئاسي الذي انسحب من السباق
وكان محور الجدل في اليومين الماضيين في
هذه الانتخابات الرئاسيه هذه اخر
المعلومات التي يعني عندنا من اسطنبول من
مقر الحمله الانتخابيه للرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان وسنتابع طبعا في رصه المشهد اولا
باول حتى وصول هذه الانتخابات الى مرحلتها
الاخيره والاعلان عن الفائز من سيكون
الرئيس الثالث عشر للجمهوريه التركيه شهر
ماذا يركز او على مدى يركز اردوغان في في
خطابه الخير وكيف يمكن النظر ايضا الى
حظوظه يعني مع ارتفاع مستوى الفقر التضخم
البطاله ايضا تراجع ملف الحريات وحقوق
الانسان كما يقول الكثير من الازمه
هذه نقطه ضعف اساسيه عنده اي موضوع
الاقتصاد ويحاولون ان يركزوا عليه كثيرا
في كل خطاباتهم كل من سمعت اليهم في هذه
الخطابات قبل قليل من مسؤوليه حزب العداله
والتنميه والدوله يتحدثون عن الاقتصاد عن
خلق الوظائف هو وعد بسته ملايين وظيفه
سيسلقها اضافه الى شان الحريات حتى
اردوغان تحدث عنه بالمناسبه المعارضه تلوم
عليهم بموضوع الحريات وبموضوع الاقتصاد
ويردون باننا رفعنا الحد الادنى للاجور
وبان
نا باننا حولنا الى دوله متقدمه اما في
موضوع الحريات اتعرف ماذا قال اردوغان في
احد خطابات وقال انا نفسي تعرضت للسجن وهو
فعلا تعرض للسجن على اثر قراءته احدى
القصائد هو يقول انها تدرس تدرس في كتب
المدارس ولكنها كانت يعني فيها تلميحات
فيما يتعلق بالجيش ويقول ان يعني انما
اذننا هي التقنات بهذا المعنى الذي يجمع
بينما هو اسلامي وديني وبين ما هو عسكري
وهذه نقطه جدليه ونقطه فيها الكثير من
الحساسيه في تركيا خاصه مع حزب يعني اسلام
يتولى السلطه محافظ بعد عقود من سيطره
العلمانيه على تركيا تلك العلمانيه التي
يقودها الطرف الاخر الان وهو كمال جليتش
دار اوغلو مرشح تحالف الامه الذي يجمع كل
تلك الاحزاب حوله حتى غير العلمانيين
استطاع ان يجمعهم كما قلنا انه استطاع جذب
بعض المحافظين وحتى حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي
الكردي والذي لم يرشح يعني مرشحا خاصه
انما دعمك في الرئاسه هذه معركه حاليه
الوطيس ستحدد معالم تركيا للمرحله المقبله
بعد فتره سيطره عليها حزب العداله
والتنميه 2019 عندما فاز اكرم امام اوغلو
ومن سوريا واش في رئاسه بلديتي اسطنبول
وانقره هل تلك الانتخابات على مفارقه
بدايه التغيير هل كانت كذلك بالفعل هل
سيفوز اردوغان في الرئاسه من الجوله
الاولى او من الجوله الثانيه ويخسر
البرلمان او العكس كله كلها اسئله مفتوحه
بانتظار الساعات الاخيره هناك الكثير من
الامور التي يمكن ان تحدد رغم الصمت
الانتخابي التي يمكن ان تحدد اكثر في مزاج
الناخر ولكن بدون شك كما تفضلت خالد
الاقتصاد يبقى عاملا اساسيا جيوب المواطن
هي الاهم بالنسبه اليه قبل اي شيء اخر
اضافه الى مواضيع الحريات التي تحدثنا عن
موضوع التدخلات الغربيه الحديث او اتهامه
امريكا وبايدن مباشره
بالتدخل في هذه الانتخابات والرغبه في
الاطاحه به الى اي مد يجد تاثيرا في قلوب
الناخبين وخاصه المؤيدين
[تصفيق]
طبعا تجد الكثير من التاييد
ارى ان المسؤولين التابعين لحزب العداله
والتنميه يعني دائما ما يصرون على ذكر
الموضوع لان المؤيدين حزب العداله
والتنميه
يصرهم كثيرا انتقاد امريكا في الواقع
ودائما ما يفعلون ذلك في معظم خطاباتهم
يتناولون الموضوع امريكا بانها هي التي
تدعم الطرف الاخر هي التي تحاول الانقلاب
علينا هي التي يعني ستكون فرحه ستكون
منزعجه ان فاز اردوغان حتى اردوغان كما
قلت لك في مباشر سابق قالها اليوم صراحه
ان بايدن اصدر اوامره لاسقاط لاسقاط حكومه
وهذا خطاب يلقى الكثير من القبول عند
حزب العداله والتنميه حتى عندما تتحدث الى
المواطنين العاديين الى سائقين تكسي الى
الموظفين في المحلات يهمهم هذا الامر جدا
يعتبرون ان اردوغان اسلامي متدين يحارب
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ويقفلها
بالمرصاد رغم العلاقات التي ظلت قويه جدا
تعرف تركيا متحالفه تحالف استراتيجي مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الا ان
العلاقات تضررت بدون شك في الفتره الاخيره
بعد الانفتاح
التركي على روسيا المعادله الان خالد هو
ان طرف المعارضه يتهم روسيا بمحاوله
التدخل بالانتخابات وطرف الموالاه والسلطه
يتهم على نيه الولايات المتحده بالتدخل في
هذه الانتخابات طيب شكرا جزيلا لك مراسلنا
او موفد العربيه من اسطنبول طاهر
بعد اكثر من عقدين من التفوق الانتخابي
اردوغان وحزبه يستعدان لاصعب معركه
انتخابيه منذ وصولهم الى السلطه بحسب
جريده الشرق الاوسط تراجع الاقتصاد التركي
ومعه مستويات المعيشه فتراجعت شعبيه
الرئيس التركي والحزب الحاكم
فاجعه الزلزال المدمر زادت الطين بالله
استطلاعات الراي تظهر تفوقا طفيفا لمنافس
اردوغان الرئيسي كليتشدار اوغلو
لكن الرئيس التركي وحزبه لن يقف مكتوف
الايدي توفير شهر مجاني للغاز الطبيعي
للمستهلكين وخفض اسعار الكهرباء وزياده
الحد الادنى للاجور ومعاشات العاملين في
القطاع العام اوراق اخرجها حزب العداله
والتنميه الى معركه الانتخابات
مخاوف من طعن السلطه في نتيجه الانتخابات
ان لم تكن في صالحهم
دعمتها تصريحات خطيره في الاول من الشهر
الجاري قال الرئيس التركي ان شعبه لن يسلم
تركيا لرئيس يدعمه الارهابيون اما وزير
الداخليه سليمان سويلو فقال ان الانتخابات
يمكن ان تصبح محاوله انقلاب سياسي يدعمها
الغرب
هذا وقال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
انه سيقبل بنتيجه انتخابات الرئاسيه رافضا
الانتقادات منافسه الرئيسي كليتش دور
اوغلو بان اعضاء الحكومه قد لا يرغبون في
نقل السلطه السلميه اردوغان في مقابله
تلفزيونيه اكدان الحزب الحاكمه وحلفاء
سيعتبرون اي نتيجه في صندوق الاقتراع
الشرعي وسيفعلون كل ما تتطلبه الديمقراطيه
زعيم المعارضه التركيه كمال كليتش دورو
جلو فقال في مقابله تلفزيونيه ايضا انه
يريد ان يكون رئيسا لدوله ديمقراطيه
حقيقيه وقال ان الشعب التركي سئم القياده
الاستبداديه اسفا اردوغان بانه يزيف
الحقائق ويفتري على الناس
تركيا
في خطر وركائز الديمقراطيه الاساسيه اي
السلطه التشريعيه والقضائيه والتنفيذيه قد
تضررت بشكل كبير نريد اصلاح هذا الامر
واريد ان اكون رئيسا يجعل من تركيا دوله
ديمقراطيه حقيقيه نريد ان نكون جزءا من
الغرب والعالم المتحضر ونريد الحريه
والديمقراطيه في بلدنا لقد سئمنا القياده
الاستبداديه بالتالي نريد تطبيق جميع
القواعد الديمقراطيه التي نص عليها
الاتحاد الاوروبي الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان يمارس دائما الالعاب القذره ولم
ارى قط رجلا يحور الحقائق ويفتري على
الناس بقدره ولكن مهما فعل فان الشعب
سيختارني انا
وقد اظهرت استطلاعات راي حديثه اجراها
مركزات دراسات الدراسات اريده
من المرجح ان يفوز الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان في الجوله الاولى من الانتخابات
الرئاسيه وفقا للنتائج فان واحدا وخمسين
فاصله ثلاثه من العشره في المئه من
المشاركين في الاستطلاع مستعدون للتصويت
لاردوغان
و44.2% لصالح كليتش دارو في حين حصل
المرشح الثالث سنان اوغن على ما يقارب 4%
من الاصوات وبحسب نتائج الدراسه فان
التحالف الشعب الذي يضم الحزب الحاكم
سيحصل على اكثر من 51% من الاصوات
بالانتخابات النيابيه
من انكر هذه المره تنضم الينا مفاده
العربيه فاطمه فهد فاطمه مرحبا بك ماذا عن
المشهد في انقره ان كان هناك خطاب ايضا
لكلتشدار
اليوم هناك تجمع وخطاب
لمنصوري افات رئيس بلديه انقره ربما
كريشتار اوغلو اكتفى بالتجمع والحجود
الذين تجمعوا بالامس حينما ظهرنا معكم في
النشرات خالد وكان جميع قاده الطاوله
السداسيه يحضرون هذا الاجتماع ويتحدثون
ويخاطبون الجماهير ويشجعونهم على التصويت
للمعارضه بدلا من اردوغان طبعا كان الحديث
اكثر يعني اكثر التركيز اكثر شيء على
العداله والحقوق يعني منع الفساد
وايقاف حكم الفرد الواحد وكذلك منصور
يافارتش في تجمعه اليوم ركز على ذلك ايضا
بانهم سيقضون على الفساد ما ان فازوا
بالرئاسه وانهم سيونهون عهد حكم الفرد
الواحد
واما نحن الان خالد نطل عليكم من امام مقر
حزب الحركه القوميه حزب الحركه القوميه هو
ثاني اكبر حزب موالي لتحالف الجمهور ولا
اردوغان طبعا الجدير بالذكر والملفت بان
قبل 2015 كان قائد هذا الحزب قائد هذا
الحزب هو
خصم من اشد خصوم اردوغان ولكن اليوم هو
يعني صديق ودود لاردوغان ويدعمه بشكل كبير
هذا المبنى من خلفي هو مقر هذا الحزب حزب
الحركه القوميه طبعا كما تعلم خالد يعني
الحركات القوميه ان كان في المعارضه او في
الاحزاب المواليه تلعب دور كبير في نسب
التصويت ونسب الفوز في هذه الانتخابات هذا
الحزب حدثت فيه انشقاقات كبيره بعد
التحالف مع اردوغان والعداله والتنميه
وابرز المنشقين اليوم والمنضمين للمعسكر
الاخر هي ميرال اكشنار زعيمه حزب الصالح
حزب الخير الحزب الصالح هو اكبر حزب او
ثاني اكبر حزب قومي في المعارضه من حيث
عدد الاصوات ومن المتوقع ان يحصل عليها
البرلمان كذلك خالد يعني نقطه مهمه
بالنسبه للحركه القوميه هي التي تخلق
خلافات واسعه في صفوف الاحزاب القوميه
سواء في المعارضه او حتى في الاحزاب
المواليه والعداء مع الاحزاب الكرديه التي
تدعم من تصنفهم تركيا بالارهابيين وهذا
بحسب طبعا الاحزاب المواليه
لاردوغان يعني هم يتهمون المعارضه بانهم
يضعون يدهم في يد حزب العمال الكردستاني
الذي يقف خلب خلف حزب حزب الاخضر او حزب
اليسار الاخضر الذي يدعم المعارضه اليوم
خالد ماذا تقول اخر استطلاعات الراي فاطمه
اخر استطلاعات الراي ما زالت متضاربه ما
زالت تختلف بشكل كبير يعني جزء منها يؤيد
كليجدار ويقول بانه سيفوز والجزء الاخر
يؤيد
اردوغان ولكن لابد ان الفت هنا خالد الى
المرشح الثالث المرشح الثالث سنان اوغان
هو ايضا منشق من تحالف الاجداد والذي على
راسه حزب النصر المعروف بمعاداه اللاجئين
بشكل كبير جدا خصوصا في السنه والنصف
الاخيره يعني يريدون باي شكل من الاشكال
اخراج اللاجئين من
تركيا وهذا يرى البعض بانه مناقض لما
يدعون منه للديمقراطيه والحريه والانفتاح
على العالم وما الى ذلك خالد شكرا جزيلا
لك مفرده العربيه الى انقره فاطمه
رابعه مستمره فيها بعد قليل يوم واحد عن
اغلاق باب التقدم على انتخابات مجلس الامه
مرزوق الغانم يرشح نفسه
اهلا بكم من جديد قبل يوم من انتهاء مهله
التقدم للترشح للانتخابات في مجلس الامه
2023 في الكويت اعلن رئيس مجلس الامه
السابق مرزوق الغانم انه تقدم باوراق
ترشحه الى انتخابات مجلس الامه عن الدائره
الانتخابيه الثانيه الغانمه اشار الى ان
تقدمه جاء بعيدا عن اي صراعات وخلافات
وانه يسعى لخدمه بلاده من اي موقع في قاعه
عبد الله السالم على حد وصفه واكد الغانم
في كلمه له على اهميه ان تكون ورقه
الاقتراع على امراه من الجميع ويجب ان
توثق عمليه الفرز بالصوت والصوره وفقا
لاخر البيانات بلغ اجمالي المتقدمين 183
مرشحا ومرشحا منذ تدشين اداره شؤون
الانتخابات عمليه التسجيل الانتخابات امه
2023 المقرر لاجراءها في السادس من يونيو
المقبل
ورسالتي الى اللجنه المنظمه والمشرفه على
الانتخابات وان شاء الله كلنا ثقه فيهم
وفي قدراتهم وفي نزاهتهم الا ان هناك
العديد من الامور لابد من تطبيقها وهي
مطالب يفترض ان لا يختلف عليها اثنان اولا
ورقه الاقتراع يجب ان تكون على مراه من
الجميع وهذا اعتقد ما في ما في اثنين
اختلفون بان الورقه يجب ان تكون مشاهده من
الجميع وراس مالها الامر الاخر يجب ان
توثق عمليه الفرس بالصوت والصوره وراس
مالها ايضا وجود كاميرا في كل لجنه واعتقد
ان هذا امر ايضا غير صعب على اللجنه
المنظمه
في السعوديه بدات الهيئه العامه للاحصاء
تنفيذ المسح الصحي الوطني 2023 لتوفير
بيانات حول صحه السكان والخدمات الصحيه
الايات التاسعه من خلال المسح الذي من
المقرر ان يستمر حتى السابع والعشرين من
الشهر الجاري الى ايجاد قاعده بيانات
موثوقه لدعم المنظمات المحليه والاقليميه
والدوليه ودعم تطوير التنافسيه السعوديه
في المجال الصحي ومراقبه التقييم والتنفيذ
البرامج الصحيه فضلا عن العمل على التحسين
الحاله الصحيه والتعزيز الخدمات بالقطاع
الاستديو ينضم الينا الكاتب والاخصائي
الاجتماعي محمد الحمزه سيد محمد حياك الله
خالد ما هو المسح الصحي الوطني ما هي
اهدافه ولماذا لا باختصار لغه الارقام هي
اللغه العلميه الحقيقيه التي يبنى عليها
حاليا كل اتخاذ القرارات والانظمه
والتشريعات بالاضافه الى ان المنظمات
الدوليه في المؤشرات الدوليه هي تعتمد على
لغه الارقام لا تعتمد على اللغه الاخباريه
او على فقط ما يظهر من تقارير كلها اطار
نظري مكتوب فكان لابد من ايجاد وسيله
علميه منظمه ومرتبه لاخراج ارقام بطريقه
صحيحه الهيئه الوطنيه للاحصاء ممثله او
تحت اشراف وزاره التخطيط هي الهيئه
السعوديه التي لديها القدره الهائله
والمنظمه ولديها الكوادر العلميه ولديها
الاجهزه التي تستطيع القيام بمثل هذه
المسوحات الوطنيه قبل فتره مثلا في عام
2010 استاذ خالد كان هناك وطني للصحه
النفسيه اوكي جميل ورائع لكن ما زال ممتد
حتى الان لم ينتهي صحيح انه في مراحل
الاخيره لكن لانه كان تحت منظمه تكون شبه
مستقله منظمه بحثيه سعوديه تحت اشراف
جامعه عالميه لكن من خلال تجاربنا السابقه
مع كل المسوحات التي تقوم بها هيئه
الاحصاء نجد ان المده لا تكاد تاخذ من ست
شهور الى سنه لاظهار النتائج وفي البدايات
لاحظنا خلال الفترات الماضيه ان هناك بعض
النتائج تبدا تظهر بشكل تدريجي بشكل
تدريجي ومهم جدا النقطه المهمه في سؤالك
يا استاذي الكريم ايش الفائده من هذه
الممسوحات حنا نتخذ قرارات مبنيه على
الارقام الصادره وللعلم فكره الصحه في هذا
المسح تعتمد على ثلاثه اشياء مهمه وفقا
لتعريف منظمه الصحه العالميه احنا نتكلم
عن الصح الجسديه الصح النفسيه الصحه
الاجتماعيه فلا فثلاثه اشياء ومح مهمه جدا
في رفع مستوى جوده حياه الناس ولو تلحظ في
كثير من الجهات الحكوميه الان جلست ترتب
نشاطاته ومشاريع وبرامج كلها تعتمد على
المعلومات الاحصائيه التي تصدرها هيئه
الاحصاء التي كانت تعتبر بسيطه ولكنها الى
حد ما مرضيه تعطينا الى حد ما هذه
المؤشرات اللي تخلينا نحدد الى وين نبغى
نتجه يعني نعطيك مثال بسيط جدا فكره مرض
الاكتئاب اللي الكل الان يشتكي منه
بالاحصاء بالارقام وجد ان مرض الاكتئاب
يصيب الشباب ما قبل سن ال 24 واذا لم
يعالج سيمتد معهم بقيه حياتهم لاحظت كيف
الاحصائيات
والكثير ما يعرف اذن معنى معناته اني لابد
اشتغل على برامج توعيه على برامج صحيه من
فتره المتوسط الثانوي فتره الجامعه لان
هذه الفتره مهمه جدا في تحقيق التوازن
النفسي
تتكلم العمليه الان طبعا انت قاعد تتكلم
عن اذا تقصد المسح الاقليه الوطني حتما
سيكون بالتعاون مع اكثر من جهه فهو لا يخص
وزاره الصحه فقط ولا يخص المركز الوطني
للصحه النفسيه ولا يخص حتى وزاره الموارد
البشريه والتنميه الاجتماعيه انت تتكلم عن
منظومه متكامله تعمل معها هيئه الاحصاء
لاخراج النتائج بالطريقه التي نريد الوصول
لها بالاضافه وهذه نقطه مره مهمه انت
تتكلم عن خطه علميه مبنيه على اصول علميه
لاخراج هل بيتصلوا علينا مثلا يسالونا عن
الحاله النفسيه والحاله الصحيه
وفود من وزاره الصحه تعمل تحاليل بس حتى
نعرف طبعا حددت عينه عينه ممثله للشعب
السعودي انت تتكلم عدد السعوديين تقريبا
انت تتكلم في الخمسه وثلاثين مليون فالعين
التقريبيه وفقا لبعض النظريات في الميه هم
اربعه الاف محدده او على مستوى على مستوى
مناطق ومحافظات المملكه في الوصول الى
وسؤالهم اسئله مقننه ومدروسه واسئله علميه
امر سهل جدا الجلسه الاحصائيه لا تاخذ سوى
45 دقيقه وفقا للتدريب الذي حصل عليه
الباحثين والاحصائيين اللي بيجمعون
المعلومات طبعا هناك خطه احصائيه للذهاب
الى كل منطقه الى الدخول الى عدد معين من
الاسر وسؤالهم هذه الاسئله اسئله طبعا هي
اسئله تعطيك المؤشرات انا في احد ما هو
عارف مثلا انه في مرض معينه ومشكله معينه
انا ما عندي الان الاجابه حتى على السؤال
ممكن ما تعطيك نتيجه صحيح انت تتكلم ليس
المساله الان مساله رصد بالدق يعني بشيء
دقيق جدا انت تاخذ بشكل عام كمؤشرات انت
لو تاخذ الان بالذات المملكه انت تتكلم عن
مناطق متراميه الاطراف عن نتكلم عن قرى في
اقصى الجنوب واقصى الشمال وتتكلم عن مدن
عن مدن كبيره مثل ايش الاسئله طبعا احنا
نتكلم عن نمط الغذاء نتكلم عن نمط الرياضه
والحياه نتكلم عن طبيعه الادويه اللي
الانسان يستخدمها حتى لو بدون وصفه طبيه
وعليها قصدانيه يعني حنا نعرف انه في كثير
من المناطق حتى بعضنا هنا في المملكه انه
قد يعتمدون على الطب البديل اكثر من
اعتمادهم مثلا على الطب العلمي الصحيح طيب
هذه اشكاليه مع مرور الزمن وفي هذا الوقت
اللي يفترض ان نسبه التعليم تكون في عاليه
طيب نبغى نشوف ليش هذه الاسباب قد تكون
بسبب بعد المراكز الطبيه قد تكون بسبب
الثقافه حتى المجال الاعلامي الصحي يدخل
هنا في محاوله كشف ومعرفه كيف ممكن نقدر
نخدم البلد وبعدين تمت العمليه اجري هذا
المسح كيف بيكون انعكاساته على الحاله
الجسديه على امكانات الصحيه المطلوبه في
بعض المناطق على
الامور النفسيه على الامور الاجتماعيه في
المتوقع وشو اللي بيتغير بصفه عامه كنظره
انسانيه للبشريه قاعدين نلحظ انه مستوى
اعمار الناس قاعده تزداد بسبب جوده الحياه
الصحيه هذا على مستوى العالم فما بالك
بالنسبه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه التي
تسعى حاليا وفق برنامج جوده الحياه الى
رفع مستوى حياه الناس الى جعلهم في وضع
مستقر وجعله في وضع متوازن اذا كنا نتكلم
يا استاذ خالد حتى عن الصحه النفسيه
والصحه بصفه عامه في داخل بيئات العمل
قاعدين نشوف الان جزء كبير جدا من المنشات
الصناعيه والصحيه قاعدين يهتم منشات
الصناعيه والحكوميه يوجد فيها حتى عيادات
طبيه يوجد فيها عيادات حتى نفسيه حتى مرشد
قد يكون حتى لو كان داخل اداره الموارد
البشريه هو لمحاوله حلول او ايجاد حلول
للناس لمختلف مشاكل يعطيك العافيه شكرا لك
محمد الحمزه الكاتب الاخصائي الاجتماعي
يعطيك العافيه
بعد قليل
[موسيقى]
رحيل الفنان الكويتيه القدير عبد الكريم
عبد القادر عن 81 عاما وانا اعين كبير في
الكويت والخليج
لليوم الخامس على التوالي اسرائيل تقصف
غزه والفصائل ترد باستهداف مستوطنات
الغلاف
يوم عن حسم رئاسه في تركيا اردوغان يقول
انه سيقبل بنتائج الانتخابات ايا كان
الاختراع يجب ان تكون على مراه من الجميع
الكويت تقفل باب الترشح للانتخابات
البرلمان غدا والغانم يتقدم ويؤكد على
شفافيه
مسح صحي وطني في السعوديه يستمر حتى
السابع والعشرين من مايو جاري
[موسيقى]
رحيل الفنان الكويتي عبد الكريم عبد
القادر عن واحد وتمارين عاما وناعم كبير
في الكويت والخليج
اهلا بكم من جديد تلقى وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان اتصالا
هاتفيا من نظيره الايراني حسين امير
عبداللهيان بحث خلاله العلاقات الثنائيه
بين البلدين والخطوات المقبله في ضوء ما
تم الاتفاق عليه اخيرا مع الصين بحث
الامير فيصل بن فرحان مع حسين امير عبد
الهيان عده مواضيع تهم البلدين
في العاصمه الاندونيسيه
الحج السعوديه مشروعه مشروعها التوعوي
سلسله رحله حج الذي يعرض بثلاث لغات
العربيه والانجليزيه والاندونيسيه توثق
سلسله رحله الحج الوثائقيه قصه ثمانيه
حجاج من اندونيسيا بادف تسليط الضوء على
تفاصيل زياره الحجاج والتسهيلات التي قدمت
لهم ابان زياره السعوديه بدايه من الخروج
من اندونيسيا مرورا الى الرحلات
والاجراءات والاستقبال واداء النسك ومن ثم
العوده الى موطنه
تجاوزت التبرعات والحمله الشعبيه السعوديه
لاغاثه الشعب السوداني اكثر من اثنين عشره
مليون و600 الف ريال وذلك بعد اطلاقها عبر
منصه الساهم بان الاشتباكات العسكريه في
السودان وصل عدد المتبرعين في الحمله
الشعبيه السعوديه الى 56 الف متبرع وتاتي
الحمله بعد التوجيه من العائله السعوديه
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز الذي اكد انها
تاتي للتخفيف في من اثار الاوضاع التي يمر
بها الشعب السوداني حاليا
من مدينه في السودان ينضم الينا موفد
العربيه محمد عثمان محمد مرحبا بك محمد
ماذا يعني في خطه وصول هذه المساعدات كيف
سيتم ايصالها الى مستحقها
وماذا عن الاوضاع بشكل عام الامنيه ايضا
اهلا الى ولايه الجزيره بالتحديد في مدينه
ودمدني وصلنا اليها مساء الامس قادمين من
مدينه بورسودان على ساحل البحر الاحمر حيث
استقبلنا هناك يعني حجم المساعدات الكبيره
التي قدمها مركز الملك سلمان
اهلا وسهلا بك
نتابع اجراءات وصول هذه
المساعدات الاغاثيه الى عدد من المدن
السودانيه تحديدا علمنا ان هذه المدينه
مدينه ود مدني ستستقبل اعداد كبيره جدا من
يعني حجم المساعدات التي ستصل الى هذه
المدينه في الايام المقبله علمنا ان مركز
الملك سلمان للغاثه قام بتوزيع عدد من
المساعدات في ولايه البحر الاحمر صباح هذا
اليوم الخطه المتبعه فيما بعد ان تصل هذه
المساعدات الى هذه المدينه مدينه ود مدني
بولايه الجزيره هذه المدينه التي تبعد
حوالي 180 كيلو متر عن مدينه الخرطوم هذه
المدينه لها بعد استراتيجي مهم جدا اولا
لانه هنالك عدد كبير جدا من النازحين
والفارين من ويلات الحرب الدائره في شوارع
الخرطوم وصلوا الى هذه المدينه على اعتبار
قربها من مدينه الخرطوم ايضا يعني ربما
تريد السلطات هنا في هذه الولايه ولانها
قريبه ان تجعل هذه المدينه مركز لتوزيع
المساعدات في حال السماح دخول المساعدات
الى وسط الخرطوم ان تنطلق هذه المساعدات
من هذه المدينه مدينه واد مدني بولايه
الجزيره هذه المدينه ايضا لها بعد
استراتيجي على اعتبار انها تضم يعني اعداد
كبيره جدا من المزارعين وانسان هذه
الولايه يعتمد بشكل اساسي على الزراعه
وفيها اخصب الاراضي الزراعيه وبالتالي
هنالك مخاوف كبيره جدا من تداعيات ربما قد
تطرح على القطاع الزراعي من راى هذه الحرب
الدائره في الخرطوم وهذا ما امن عليه وزير
الماليه في اجتماعه مع ولاه الولايات
الذين حضروا الى هذه المدينه وكان هنالك
اجتماع موسع تم فيه الحديث حول تامين وصول
التقاوه وكذلك ايضا تامين الوقود لضمان
نجاح الموسم الزراعي فيما يتعلق بدور
الايواء هنالك اكثر من 20 دار ايوا منتشر
في هذه المدينه هذه المدينه تستقبل عشرات
الالاف من النازحين سواء كان من الخرطوم
او حتى من مدن من غرب السودان تاثرت
وتضررت بالنزاع بين الجيش وايضا قوات
الدعم السريع
مثلا لو ضاع الامنيه بشكل عام اذا كان
هناك من تطورات ايضا ميدانيه مهمه محمد
نعم هذه المدينه تعتبر من اامن المدن وهذه
الولايه ايضا لا تدور فيها اشتباكات وهذا
مفهوم طبعا على اعتبار ان هذه التدفقات
الكبيره لسكان ولايه الخرطوم حضروا الى
هذه الولايه القريبه على اعتبار انها امنه
وهنالك تامين كبير يتم على
المشتقات البتروليه يتم تامين على الامداد
الدوائي وكذلك ايضا الامداد الغذائي
الواصل الى هذه المدينه علمنا ايضا ان
هنالك تنسيق على مستوى الفرق العسكريه
وعلى مستوى قيادات هذه المناطق العسكريه
من بورسودان من ولايه البحر الاحمر وصولا
الى ولايه الجزيره وغيرها ايضا من
الولايات يكون هنالك تنسيق بين قيادات
المناطق العسكريه وذلك لتامين وصول
المساعدات وكذلك ايضا المشتقات البتروليه
لضمان استمرار الموسم ونجاح الموسم
الزراعي الذي يبدا في الايام المقبله على
اعتبار ان الخريف على الابواب ومواطن هذه
الولايه وغيرها ايضا من الولايات المحيطه
تعتمد بشكل اساسي على الزراعه وبالتالي
فيما يتعلق بالجوانب الامني هذه الولايه
والولايات المحيطه هي امنه وليست بها اي
نزاعات فقط يتركز النزاع في ولايه الخرطوم
وكذلك ايضا في ولايه غرب دارفور بالتحديد
في مدينه الجنينه شكرا لك محمد عثمان مفضل
عربيه من مدينه مدينه ود مدني في السودان
نعت اوساط خليجيه وعربيه الفنان الكويتي
عبد الكريم عبد القادر الذي وافته المنيه
عن واحد وثمانين عاما قدم فيها الراحل
واعمالا خالد ارتبطت بوجدان محبي التقرير
التالي يوججز قليلا من كثير سيد الوداع
يا مغرب عن ديارك متغرب الصوت الجريح كما
اعتاد محبه تسميته رحل الرجل الثمانيني
تاركا ارثا فنيا كبيرا جاوز السته عقود من
مئات الاغنيات التي رسمت قصص عشق لا تنتهي
في فضاء الموسيقى الكويتيه والخليجيه
غربه لن تستطيع تغيير رمز من رموز الفن
الخليجي عبد الكريم عبد القادر
وطنا
[موسيقى]
لها صوت الكويت الاكثر عراقه وصرخه بلاده
حين داهمها الغزو لم يفارق ترابها واظل
صوته الرقيق هادرا فوق اصوات المدافع حتى
عادت ارضه الى ناسها
جرح
غراب تيه افكاري
وبين في الهوى اسرار بداياته نجاحاته ظلت
متالقه بصوته واصوات فناني الكويت والخليج
طوال عقود وحضوره الدائم في وجدان عشاق
الموسيقى الاصيله لم يغب يوما رغم غيابه
عن الحفلات الموسيقيه لعقود
اخر ليله تجمعنا
وداعيه اعز الناس ودعنا لطالما كان الوداع
في اغنيات عبد الكريم عبد القادر عنوان
اللامعا رغم الشجن وقاسيا غير مره مثل ما
كان وداعه المفاجئ والهادئ طوال تجربه
حفظت اصاله الكلمه وعراقه اللحن ناسجا
بصوته المخملي اغنيات خالده في تاريخ
الموسيقى العربيه
مكانه الخالي معهد
الملك محد
ملائكه سته عقود من الفن الفارق في مسيره
الاغنيه الكويتيه والخليجيه يتركها الراحل
لعشاقه لتبقى مسيرته الخالده عنوانا للولا
الذي يطرا على بال محبيه ولا يجدون ملاذا
منه الا في حنجره الصوت الجريح
[موسيقى]
عليه الولا
وطني على باله يا طريق عليه الولاه واطني
على
بالا يا مرحبا لا يضوى
على بابي
على بالي يطير عليه
[موسيقى]
رحم الله ابو خالد واسكنه فسيح جناته ابرز
اليوم الخامس على التوالي اسرائيل تقصف
غزه والفصائل وترد باستهداف مستوطنات
الغلى
يومنا عن حسم الرئاسه في تركيا اردوغان
يقول انه سيقبل بنتائج الانتخابات ان كانت
ورقت الاقتراع يجب ان تكون على مراه من
الجميع
الكويت تقفل باب الترشيخ لانتخابات
البرلمان غدا والغانم يتقدم ويؤكد على
شفافيه
مسح وطني في السعوديه صحي يستمر حتى
السابع والعشرين من مايو الج
[موسيقى]
يل الفنان الكويتي عبد الكريم عبد القادر
عن واحد وثمانين عاما وناعي كبير في
الكويت والخليج
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات